je suis sorti j'ai pris une cuite
fantastique
[Applaudissements]
jour pourtant Julie
partie de notre vie
je crois que ce jour-là
rien
ne consoles je les bonbons c'est bon
c'est bon je les bonbons c'est bon c'est
bon j'ai Les bonbons c'est bon c'est bon
j'ai Les bonbons c'est bon
c'était mieux aussi autant qu'à
Fouilleux tout avait commencé le 13
octobre personne n'avait jamais entendu
chanter Étienne Roblot personne ne
savait s'il en était capable le
président directeur général d'une grande
marque de disques plus signe un contrat
exclusif
l'instrument qui va vous mener à la
gloire
l'ensemble des clausées est assez
classique mais enfin il y a deux ou
trois éléments et tiennent qu'il va
falloir respecter très strictement je
vous les énonce rapidement
vous ne devrez pas changer votre
apparence physique
ni même votre état social si vous ne
devrez pas vous marier pendant les deux
tiers de ce contrat
quand je parle de votre apparence
physique vous ne devrez pas vous couper
les cheveux
de plus de 10 ans de 3 cm ne pas boire
et la moustache et puis il y a un
certain nombre de choses naturellement
que vous ne devrez pas faire non plus
j'aimerais que vous montriez le je sais
pas monsieur
standard classique à part les quelques
clauses particulières notamment
concernant l'aspect de l'aspect de
l'image que nous voulons faire des
tiennes oui doit être très typé donc
supposer que nous commençons de le de
créer une image autour de lui et que
brusquement il décide de se mettre les
bigoudis ou bien de porter des nœuds
papillons ça me cadrerait plus du tout
avec le personnage ça je pense que vous
êtes d'accord il ne faut pas non plus
que il ait une une vie privée par trop
chargée pendant les premiers temps du
moins du lancement Étienne Étienne c'est
un grand moment dans votre existence
qui sait demain votre nom qui lui
rappelle sur tous les murs de Paris ce
serait peut-être la nouvelle idole
Michel que pensez-vous du contrat
puisque notre ami Étienne n'arrive pas à
lui à se décider il a l'air de tourner
de son contrat comme moi je trouve ça
très bien c'est bien moi Étienne votre
contrat de mariage avec la postérie
alors une première une la première page
un petit paraphe la désinitiale
suffiront
appliquez comme un écolier
et une signature sur la dernière page
voilà
bravo
vous faites la même chose il y en a un
pour vous un pour nous
et maintenant nous sommes en quelque
sorte mariés sous le régime de la
communauté
en bas
je suis sûr que vous aurez le sacré cœur
en réduction parce que celui-ci
appartient à la municipalité je crois
pas qu'il nous le savait bien et bien je
remets une copie du contrat à Michel
Dettinger je conserve l'autre mais c'est
Simon voici plus de questions
alors Étienne ne nous reste plus qu'à
travailler à travailler à travailler
très dur Etienne et souvenez vous ce que
je vous ai dit alors en ce qui concerne
votre vie privée il est stipulé kundovez
pas vous marier au moins pendant la
première moitié du contrat de manière à
ce que nous puissions vraiment créer le
personnage faire l'image qui vous rendra
ses lèvres les mousses et jolies
moustaches il ne faudra pas non plus
toucher cette coiffure et alors gardez
toujours cet air simple sincère qui a
attiré l'attention de de votre de votre
impression et la nôtre et pour le reste
nous nous en chargeons Étienne et bien
Étienne il me reste plus qu'à vous
remercier Étienne
voici maintenant avec nous pour le
meilleur et pour le dire j'étais
j'espère que bien que ça sera le
meilleur merci à vous aussi monsieur
c'était un jeu nous espérons
je vais vous demander de vous présenter
commence par Monsieur
23 ans le journaliste
Jean-Pierre Frambois 22 ans journaliste
deux journalistes et un artiste qui sont
en train de monter une opération
d'envergure
où est-ce que vous êtes journaliste tous
les deux
journal de jeune qui s'appelle
salut les copains
est-ce qu'on peut avoir un chiffre un
million un million vous avez une idée du
nombre de jeunes que vous touchez
d'ailleurs ce tirage
pendant 5 ans ils ont regardé fabriquer
des chanteurs des chanteurs qui sans eux
ne seraient sans doute jamais devenus
des idoles
un jour ils ont décidé d'inventer
eux-mêmes ils ont inventé Étienne Roblot
un personnage physique il y a des
attitudes
innées enfin naturelles qui sont assez
extraordinaires qu'il a précisé plus que
le mot extraordinaire je sais pas moi
que je trouve enfin
parce que c'est une chose où il faut
participer il faut au départ jouer le
jeu avec lui mais après on dégoûte des
tas de choses vraiment très très bien on
va dire c'est comique
très visuel à mon avis et beaucoup plus
que que sa comique d'attitude
d'expression qui peut avoir sur son
visage dans sa manière de bouger dans sa
manière de se tenir debout de d'agir
dans la vie et c'est un comique qui est
naturel c'est pas du tout Français
travailler mais vraiment à l'état brut
et il a toujours été comme ça autant que
je m'en souviens il y a des gens qui
peuvent tenir à un verre et qui
deviennent absolument sinistre et
d'autres qui tiennent un verre et qui
sont irrésistibles j'ai l'impression
qu'il tient la partie plutôt à la
seconde catégorie des gens qui avec
n'importe quoi dans la main son rôle moi
il me rappelle Tati autant le jour boeuf
et ça et c'est pas du tout
une volonté de copie Tati c'est purement
inné
Étienne est-il aussi drôle que le
prétent de ces managers pour le savoir
ne lui avons donné rendez-vous à 9
heures du matin
à l'époque il habitait chez la vedette
de la collectionneuse et des jeunes
9h du matin c'était peut-être un peu tôt
voici Etienne Roblot à l'état brut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas une merde pour te réveiller ça
[Applaudissements]
on se doutait bien que on se préparant à
tourner on te prendrait vraiment dans le
lit comme ça
[Applaudissements]
quelle vie
je suis sorti j'ai pris une cuite
fantastique
[Applaudissements]
normal
ton maquis ou après je préfère
[Applaudissements]
trouver ça dans sa chambre il y a pas
pris la mienne quand même eu de la
chance puis voilà enfin je vais garder
il était drôle je me suis posée
il y a longtemps il y a un bon mois et
demi maintenant
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu sa tête
c'est une c'est un jeune homme de
compagnie qui fait le thé il devait
faire le matin et le soir
entre deux je suis pas gâté
[Applaudissements]
tous les deux on m'a pas laissé rentrer
que c'était elle quand même alors je les
emmené tous les deux se promener dans
une allée bien bien fleurie avec des
grands hommes je les ai lâché tous les
deux et on a un qui est resté c'est lui
elle était sur un arbre se promener
normalement si une vieille dame qui a
dit oh là là vous avez vu il y a un
singe qui s'est échappé
il y a trois personnes qui sont venues
depuis 10 15 20 puis on vous donne
rendez-vous il y avait 300 personnes
alors complètement en dessous de là
parce qu'il fait que l'autre elle
piaillet parce que comme elle est
froussard comme c'est pas permis vous
pouvez pas descendre et puis ailleurs et
tout le monde a rien même les gens du
jardin qui sont venus avec des filets ou
c'est qu'il est l'animal et tout tu as
pas une proposition pour les mettre à
Medrano tous les deux non
mais j'ai commencé le maquillage de
Roblot
il se peut encore il fait semblant de
sauter sous l'eau sur les tableaux tu as
vu les résultats à côté mais pas très à
droite
tu trouves qu'il est davantage
pique-nique aux VIP
et toi
quelle luxe tu as vu il y a 15 tableaux
que ça fait ça fait chaud pour combien
de millions et puis là ça fait 14
millions et puis là ça en fait mais
quelle vie quand même quel luxe et c'est
beau quand même alors elle me dit tu es
complètement fou tu es un bourgeois
alors on rentre ici elle me parle que de
tableau magnifique de salle de bains
comment vous allez faire quand vous
aurez des tableaux de 15 millions comme
vous dites avec le maquillage
on les mettra dans des coffres forts
elle ressemble d'ailleurs à quelqu'un de
très connu je sais plus qui mais
peut-être
belle
blue parce qu'il se lave pas très bien
manger des trucs et qu'elle a des trucs
dans les dents
[Applaudissements]
tu veux pas nous chanter une de tes
chansons d'amour
La Traviata voulait que
tu veux
quand on se lève comme toi qu'on est
jeune on doit être de bonne humeur on
doit pouvoir chanter allez vas-y ah
ouais moi je suis pas de bonne humeur le
matin comme ça
c'est trop tôt pour que je chante je
suis connecté
les coques pas les poules mais les
coques tout au moins genre à 6h du matin
5h du matin
dans la vie faut pas s'en faire moi je
m'en fais pas
il y a le pour le premier stade qui a
été de décider ensemble quand il
détienne pouvait très bien chanter qu'à
partir du moment il faisait mourir de
rire 10 personnes il pouvait en faire
mourir de rire 10 millions c'est le
premier stade le deuxième stade ça a été
bon si on veut le faire chanter
à faire exactement
[Musique]
il faut lui trouver des chansons à Paris
aujourd'hui si on a ce problème on va
trouver Éric Charden
tu lui as dit qu'il allait travailler
pour la première fois que sa vie
aujourd'hui
non mais non
je crois quelqu'un il faut pas lui dire
qu'on va travailler
[Musique]
Fernandez
d'un paysan quoi qui
ose pas dire à une fille qui l'aime
c'est à dire pendant 20 ans c'est atroce
parce que elle devient vieille grosse et
tout enfin maintenant alors ce sera
vraiment une musique si tu veux vraiment
française mais avec un son tout à fait
tout à fait nouveau ils sont très
comment on fait maintenant on va le
faire commencer par des grelots
après tu auras des cloches à faire gling
gling gling gling gling gling gling
gling gling gling
[Musique]
c'est la fête au village
et Fernandez bien habillé
sa jolie gras de à quoi
[Musique]
depuis longtemps
voilà
oh mon dieu quelle est Maëlle et elle
fait moins de ses 60 ans
[Musique]
couleur miramel
on dirait un gâteau à pétition là tu
attends tu vas le faire chanter là je
voudrais bien essayer un petit peu oui
c'est la fête au village et leur
Fernandez
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
c'est la fête au village
les perdants c'est bien habillé
il habite sa jolie papa
à pois jaune sur son costume
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et Fernandez
sa jolie gravates à pois jaune sur son
festivalier
et aujourd'hui c'est la fête au village
éternellement c'est bien habillé
[Musique]
la vie sa jolie gras durs
alors vous allez me faire cette chose
toute bête à vous maintenant
à vous maman
[Musique]
maman
grâce à Eric Charden Etienne a
maintenant un répertoire il lui reste à
apprendre à chanter Étienne va donc chez
Madame Charlot c'est sa première leçon
allez détendez-vous et attaquer
[Musique]
maman voilà
maman viens droit devant maman
encore une fois c'est faux voilà
accrochez-vous ma maman lâchez votre
ventre
voilà c'est bien
[Musique]
bien très bien non non non non non
non attaquer droit
[Musique]
donc j'ai pas restez toujours droit
la voix pas l'individu
[Musique]
vous entendez qu'il y en a qui sont pas
juste il faut placer droit vous
installez sur la taille et les envoyer
devant
pensez que vous chantez ça doit être
comme dans la vie mais multiplier c'est
tout alors on recommence
[Musique]
on dirait que vous avez fait un 100 m
pas du tout respirer normalement des
petits coups d'air après le deuxième
accord
j'essaie de pas y penser
plus rien vous lâchez votre ventre
[Musique]
on va abandonner les mamans pour faire
les mimi alors à peine ouvert la bouche
et bien tranquille votre souffle mimi
mimi
[Musique]
allez avec moi entrer dedans
allez
allez je sais vous souffrez
parce que vous lâchez tout votre souffle
alors d'ailleurs c'est mieux vous vous
décontractez mais je vais vous donner la
notion du diaphragme maintenant alors on
va faire des attaques n'ayez pas cet air
effrayé tranquille c'est tout et vous
faites mais
à vous
[Musique]
tant qu'on est en train de poursuivre
dans une basse-couronne
de cette respiration c'est ça mais
attendez on va faire autre chose alors
on va essayer des Happy
décontractez-vous vous avalez votre
parapluie à chaque instant allez
bien allez
[Musique]
décontractez vous rigolez
avec vos épaules respirer là un petit
coup d'air
des difficultés avec son diaphragme oh
oui c'est évident mais enfin il est
tellement contracté qu'on peut pas se
faire une opinion positive vous ne
trouvez plus contracté que d'autres
élèves que vous avez eu ça me surprend
particulièrement parce que étant donné
le personnage c'est très surprenant
avec ses épaules enfin mais pour une
première fois c'est pas du tout inquiète
combien de temps pensez-vous qu'il vous
faudra pour en faire un une vedette très
rapidement on pourra obtenir un résultat
parce que la voix est très bonne je le
sens non mais un mois quelques semaines
on peut très bien on travaille encore
deux fois par semaine un peu plus quand
même un peu plus oui presque tous les
jours lorsque je parle d'un mois presque
tous les jours
qui sont devenus très célèbres oui il y
en a pas mal par exemple là vous me
surprenez sur le moment
qui puisse vous dire Mireille Mathieu
par exemple et puis j'ai Georgette
Lemaire et puis j'ai aussi des comédiens
et qu'est-ce que vous pensez c'est en
comparant Étienne à ces gens qui sont
déjà devenus célèbres si vous vous
rappelez leur première leçon comment
pouvez-vous la situer par rapport à ce
que vient de faire Étienne la seconde
puisque c'est sa première leçon et bien
je trouve qu'il est particulièrement
plus appliqué c'est ce qu'il a paralysé
complètement oui c'est très surprenant
vous pensez qu'il est un bel avenir
alors oui sûrement sur aucun doute c'est
un personnage il est intelligent ça se
voit la voix sera bonne suivra enfin
sera très bien c'est la guerre c'est la
guerre nous sommes en train de partir
c'est finalement dans notre activité
c'est
la première vraie responsabilité où on
s'engage personnellement on engage
quelqu'un personnellement jusqu'à
maintenant c'était une expérience vous
avez pris des risques je m'excuse
financiers non il y a pas il y a aucun
risque financier le prix il y a
simplement un engagement à Paris
contient vis-à-vis de tout un métier en
fait je veux dire vous risquez de vous
courir de ridicule
c'est bon c'est bon j'ai les bonbons 12
janvier 1968
Étienne entre pour la première fois dans
un studio d'enregistrement
elle servait le champagne
[Musique]
chez Monsieur
bon j'ai Les bonbons
c'est bon
[Musique]
la sortie des classes
les gosses orients lui
acheter des glaces moi
je la trouvais belle
[Musique]
c'est bon
polo il y a des trucs là qui clochent un
peu là
je m'en fève pas et c'est le lendemain
13 janvier que tiennent Roblot
enregistre son premier disque
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la fête au village
d'ici la vie
changeons les travaux
[Musique]
je suis sûr que j'aurais